when moli kulen was just 9 years old he
got a call from pop star Michael Jackson
who invited the culen family to visit
his California estate Neverland Ranch
moli began spending all of his vacations
there and built a friendship with
Jackson based on a shared understanding
of childhood Fame Arrested Development
and pushy stage fathers who grew abusive
as mcau explained to New York Magazine
we had very similar experiences in
childhood it's not like I can just bump
into people on the street and say oh you
too it doesn't happen that often
Michael's still a kid I'm still a kid
we're both going to be about eight years
old forever in some place because we
never had a chance to be eight when we
actually were that's kind of the
beautiful and the cursed part of our
lives